buenos días los líderes de la alianza ya
han aprobado su plan estratégico para
los próximos 10 años se trata de
multiplicar el número de fuerzas en el
este de europa se va a pasar de 40.000
efectivos a 300.000 fuerzas que pueden
actuar de forma rápida en cualquier
punto del flanco oriental de la alianza
pero se trata en cualquier caso de una
protección total de norte a sur de este
a oeste se trata del mayor despliegue en
el continente desde la guerra fría la
otan se compromete así a proteger
firmemente y cada centímetro del
territorio de la alianza en el último
plan estratégico de hace 12 años no se
hablaba en absoluto de rusia de hecho se
la consideraba un socio estratégico la
china ni siquiera se la mencionaba para
que se haga una idea de lo que ha
cambiado el mundo ahora a rusia se la
considera una amenaza directa a la
seguridad de la alianza y además a china
se la considera un rival sistémico
además los aliados también se han
comprometido al menos a destinar un 2%
del gasto en defensa a una de las
grandes peticiones
la alianza de los últimos años pero lo
cierto es que en 2024 la gran mayoría de
los aliados ya habrá conseguido o
incluso superará este porcentaje por
último los aliados han dado la
bienvenida a poder invitar a finlandia y
a suecia como países miembros de la otan
de hecho se espera que las próximas
semanas se pueda ya iniciar el proceso
de ratificación para que estos países
puedan entrar en la alianza una decisión
histórica para estos países nórdicos